trying to spin it on his finger that
didn't work try to spin it okay he spins
a little bit again dribbling around does
a little twist does a little turn and
then he just tackles this Chinese boy he
got in his way and then Nome recovers
pretty well they're they're laughing you
know he kind of Pats the kid on the back
hugs him a little so he's a good
politician Gavin Newsome but he just
destroyed that little Chinese that
little Chinese
child got just a couple inches in the
way of something that Gavin Nome wanted
in this case winning a basketball game
and Nome just wrecked this kid took him
to the pavement can you even imagine
what he's going to do to Joe
Biden if Gavin Nome is willing to do
this to a Chinese child to win a
basketball game what is he going to do
to geriatric Joe Biden to win the
presidency a lot more than tackle him I
bet that guy that guy is ruthless
ruthless